est soigneusement planifiée.
Un point de presse dev
la Cour suprême du Canada.
a a a a a a a a a a a a a a a ,
les militants anti-avortement
sont revigorés à la veille
de leur grande marche annuelle
à Ottawa.,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,,
Campagne Québec-Vie
- Et a a a a a vu une brèche
exactement, avec l'arrêt Roe vs
Wade, qui a été renversé ou qui
veveveveveveveveveveveveveveveve
possible annulation du droit à
l'avortement par la Cour suprême
des É
croient-ils, quittttt
redonner un souffle
à leur mouvement au Canada.
retentissements culturels
sur toute la planisisisisis
spécialement au Canada. On est
juste à côté des États-Unis.
- Au même moment, le
gouvernement Trudeaueeeeee
aussi pour se positionner.
JEAN-YVES DUCLananananananananaé
- L'évolution de la situation
aux Étausususususus rappelle
à toutes et à tous que nous
ne pouvons pas tenir ces droits
et lib
rarararararaux annoncent le
financement de nouveaux projets
pour améliorer l'accèse e e e eu
n'écarte pas la possibilité de
légiférer pour protéger le droit
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
prststststststre du Canada
- Nous, on veut comprendre
ce qui est... comment on va
p p p p p p p p p p p p p p p .
Je pense que c'est quelque chose
sur quoi la vaste majorité
- Bien que la Cour suprême
du Canada ait décriminalisé
l'avor g g g g g g g g g g g g t
n'a r r r r r r r encadrer cette
pratique ou en garantir l'accès.
Mais selon certains juristes,
un cadre légrararararararait
avoir l'effet inverse et
restreindre l'accès pa
Le gouvernement en est
conscient.
- rarararararararararararararare
une bonne idée si on parle
d d d d d d d'assurer et de
garantir l'accès à l'avortement.
- L'enjeu revient sous
les projecteurs en pleine course
conservateur. Des députés
accusent les libéraux de raviver
le débat pour des raisons
partisanes.
PIERRE PAUL-HUS,
- Je trouve ça fascinant de voir
que c'est Justin Trudeau et
libéraux qui ramènent le débat
sur l'avortement parce que
de notre côté, on deman
était réglée.
n n n n n n n n n n n n n n n ns
sont remarquées. Elle est landnt
de la course conservatrice.
des appuis.
Le gouvernement Trudeau
ce qui se passe aux États-Unis
pour marquer des points
Canada. Mais les libéraux savent
très bien que l'avortement
conservateurs, et ils ont choisi
le jour de leur premier débat
officiel de la course à la
ch
à l'avant-scène.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-C